hey youtubers is Charlie surprise
holiday present from marvel Benedict
Cumberbatch as Doctor Strange full up
not concept art like actual pictures of
him in the costume some you are probably
asking like why are they releasing
teaser images if the movie isn't out
till next year and they're trying to
promote Captain America Civil War
well it's Stanley's birthday and
Benedict Cumberbatch is starring in the
Sherlock Christmas special in a couple
days so I think they just wanted to take
advantage of all those things happening
but you kind of see the spectrum of the
character and these different teaser
images like you start out at the
beginning of the story he's this
brilliant surgeon that gets into an
accident his hands are crushed he can't
practice medicine anymore after blowing
all of his wealth looking for healers to
fix his hands he hears about someone
called the ancient one in the Himalayas
asks that he fix him the ancient one
played by Tilda Swinton in this movie
see something good in him and teaches
him the ways of magic till he ascends to
the rank of sorcerer supreme now as he's
in the costume here like we're with the
eye of agamotto that is when he has
ascended to sorcerer supreme and yes I
totally think that the eye of agamotto
is the sole gem I totally think there's
an infinity gem in there if you're gonna
give the soul gem to someone that's not
Adam warlock you probably give to dr.
strange but a lot of you have probably
seen images from the set of chiwetel
ejiofor walking around with Benedict
Cumberbatch she would tell is playing
Baron Mordo
dr. Strange's greatest human nemesis now
the thing about Mordo is that he's also
a student of the ancient one but he
feels kind of like the redheaded
stepchild when Stephen strange comes
along because he's been there a lot
longer he's like I should get to be
sorcerer supreme why you know why are
you picking this outsider so Mordo forms
a pact with otherworldly powers which
will be played by mass Mickelson Mads
Mikkelsen is gonna be like the main
villain of the movie so Baron Mordo is a
villain but there's always someone
bigger someone from another dimension
this is what Kevin Feige was talking
about recently he did this interview
where he's talking about Maz mickelson
being the main villain he said there are
things that are much more terrible than
you would find on earth things from
other dimensions so I think there's a
dead giveaway that Mickelson is playing
Dormammu now he's from what is called
the Dark Dimension this picture here is
is a picture of another dimension but
it's just an example of what it's going
to look like when Doctor Strange is
hopping dimensions if you guys have seen
ant-man
they talk about the
awesome zone that's really like a small
state of existence within our own
reality it's not like jumping to a
different dimension it's a little bit
different but it's similar to what's
gonna be going on in Doctor Strange you
know traveling to this other reality so
think about ant-man going into the
quantum zone then dropping a bunch of
acid that's what it's gonna look like
when dr. strange is hopping from
dimension to dimension really the big
thing to get hype about Doctor Strange
obviously he's part of the Illuminati
like the most powerful organization in
the Marvel Universe I don't think
they're gonna do that yet
but I do think we will get some Easter
eggs for Doctor Strange working with the
Avengers
now infinity war still a ways off that's
not happening till after Thor Ragnarok
so it's more likely that they would
tease Ragnarok at the end of Doctor
Strange but they could do any number of
things but if you really want to go
crazy about something I mean I mean it's
gonna be completely amazing
you have Benedict Cumberbatch Chiwetel
Ejiofor Tilda Swinton in Mass mikkelsen
all in the same movie they are going to
crush it seriously Marvel does a great
job at casting like Chris Evans is
amazing Robert Downey jr. is totally
Tony Stark but when you talk about like
the prestige class of actor like these
are some of the greatest actors in the
world right now so I just I can't wait
to see what they look like inside the
Marvel Universe that to me is like the
real question to you know like what is
could happen when they come into this
Marvel Universe they're amazing drama
actors but there's like a certain level
of predetermination because of all the
other things that are going on in the
Marvel Universe so they kind of have to
fit this into that but if James Gunn can
make guardians of the galaxy and make it
feel completely unique in this larger
Marvel Universe then they can totally do
Doctor Strange really like the proof of
concept for crazy magic is guardians of
the galaxy if you can make a talking
raccoon in a talking tree compelling you
can do just about anything have it it
posed to featurette for this a little
bit ago it uses mostly concept art I'll
go ahead and play it again right now it
just is just teasing the idea of
Benedict Cumberbatch is Doctor Strange
and how this is different from the other
Marvel movies continuing through phase 3
we introduced Doctor Strange you need a
spectacular happy to portray this
character in the fact that Benedict
Cumberbatch has agreed to do this raw is
huge fronts Benedict he's got an
incredibly complicated emotional
structure going on it's one of the
things that's important to us
in telling a magical story is keeping it
grounded but still leaving enough room
to have really cool and unique visual
ideas to explore
what you can expect from this Doctor
Strange movie is a mind trip action bill
how do you put that on a screen within
this cinematic universe that is you know
one of the primary goals that movie so
let me know in the comments like looking
at these pictures like what are you most
excited to see or are you just like
really excited to find out what's going
on with the eye of a komodo in the soul
gem Thanos is still kind of sitting the
bleacher seats just like licking his
lips don't forget that Thanos at the end
of age of Ultron and that post-credits
scene was like fine I'll do it myself so
you know he grabs the gauntlet and he's
going to be pursuing the gems I don't
think that he's going to acquire a lot
of them till for Ragnarok though because
Captain America Civil War is gonna be
like the big movie of the spring just
expect to start to see more doctor
strange things around then like once
they get past that they will be
full-bore promoting Doctor Strange and
because the movie isn't out till
November I'm expecting Marvel to come
back to comic-con I do think that they
will do a Comic Con presentation with
Benedict Cumberbatch Owen something
really funny - I know I kind of
name-drop guardians of the galaxy did
you know the guardians of the galaxy -
is going to be released at the same time
it's Star Wars Episode 8 it's gonna be
crazy
that'll be like the biggest weekend in
the history of the planet so really big
news I actually have some family
mandatory vacation that I have to go on
but there is a game of Thrones video
that I'm working on for tonight HBO just
released a teaser image of bran that
leads me to believe that they're going
to change a couple things from the books
it's actually a pretty big deal it might
not seem like a big deal but what this
implies is actually pretty big there's
also that arrow video that I'm working
on that's not quite as crazy as like the
stuff that just dropped today so I'm
gonna get through that stuff and I'll
post the arrow video as soon as possible
so yes I'm gonna be on vacation for like
a day or two but I'll still be posting
videos so so no worries there you can
follow me on Twitter and Facebook if
you're not sure when videos are posting
well guys wait for all that stuff you
can click here for my last Captain
America Civil War video and you can
click here for all my Game of Thrones
season 6
teaser videos thank you so much for
watching everybody let's high five I'll
see you guys tonight
you